let's talk about this
roe v wade which is
it's uh
you can't turn on the news without
seeing this by the way it's pretty ugly
and something that's been going on for a
while it was a concern
when uh uh
supreme court justices were chosen they
kind of knew this day was coming it's
officially here so roe v wade uproar
mcconnell calls for prosecution for of
supreme court leaker
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
called for the department of justice to
investigate and pursue criminal charges
against those responsible for leaking
draft supreme court decision that would
overturn roe v wade mcconnell uh went on
uh to rip his democratic opponents for
politicizing the court and repeatedly
using leaks in an attempt to force
changes mcconnell's comments after
political publisher leaking leaked draft
copy of justin samuel alito's decision
in an upcoming ruling on a mississippi
abortion law the ruling if adopted by
four other justices would overturn roe v
roey roe v wade which legalized abortion
nationwide in 1973 supreme court chief
justice directs marshall to investigate
league uh calls out egregious breach of
trust anyways this thing's going all
over the place so what are your thoughts
about what's going on here with the
story
well i think it's a travesty i think uh
roe v wade was established law for 50
years in my opinion and maybe you know
on paper i know it was never codified as
you know federal law
um
i don't think for a second that this the
problem here is the leaker it's very
telling that you know mcconnell's going
after the leaker rather than
perhaps having a conversation about the
three justices who said on uh their in
their hearing that they would not
overturn this ruling
that those are three acts of perjury you
know you could go after just as much as
this leaker
um
i am for a woman's right to choose uh
because i am not a woman so i cannot
possibly fathom what it's like and i
know there are arguments to be made that
you know that does that shouldn't
you know be a part of the conversation
um
but it's it is it who benefits who
benefits from this
you have a base of republicans and uh
their voter base who are christian and
that's a very firm belief my brother's
very anti um
abortion he's a staunch staunch catholic
was a republican lawmaker for a long
time but also a never trumper so there's
all kinds of shades there um
but
it strikes me that this is a cudgel that
is uh an overwhelming distraction i
don't think it's going to make it all
the way
uh it is distracting us from bigger
issues which we which we seem to be
ignoring at our peril like climate
change in my opinion
and uh once again
it is just uh
i don't know it's it's such it's so hard
to talk about because it's it's go ahead
adam
no
it's there's clearly no correct answer
in in
there's if you don't want an abortion
don't no
what was interesting we talked about
this when we were in the old office and
and you said well when when should you
have an abortion i said yeah well you
know
uh you know you should have up to x
amount of months is what i said oh
really do you think that long five
months whatever it was i said let me
actually go around the
office
and i asked everyone every woman in the
office and then i started asking men
okay when shouldn't abortion be okay
you know well six weeks uh 12 weeks 15
weeks to get all these different answers
and i remember just getting different
answers from everybody i think we can
all be in agreement that there's the
first second third trimester you should
not be able to have an abortion during
the third trimester
that's essentially what everyone was
comfortable saying sure
during the first trimester people felt
very comfortable saying well in the
first 10 weeks 12 weeks yes that seems
very reasonable the gray area is
basically that
that
20 week mark
right where the baby is four to five
months old is it a life is it not a life
uh that's
that's the deeper question but even even
in there are cases in third trimester
where an abortion is a medical necessity
or you have to choose between the life
of the baby and the life of the mother
imagine come having to make that
decision i mean there's this post going
around instagram right now that's really
cool i'm not pro-murdering babies i'm
pro-becky who found out at her 20-week
anatomy scan that the infant she had
been so excited to bring into this world
had developed without life-sustaining
organs i'm pro-susan who was sexually
assaulted on her way home from work only
to come to the horrific realization that
her assailant planted his seed in her
when she got a positive pregnancy test
result a month later i'm pro-teresa who
hemorrhaged due to a placental abruption
causing her parents spouse and children
to have to make the impossible decision
of whether to save her or her unborn
child i'm pro-kathy it goes on and on
and on and all these cases where this
this ruling
is barbaric the the thing that
i as three men talking about when i know
whether women should have an abortion i
think is
is uh is almost ironic however
i also think it's a very ironic that you
know what percentage of congress people
are men 95 percent and they're the ones
making these decisions of what a woman
should do with her body and they'll have
quite rich by the way if they if they're
their daughters but the whole thing
they'll have access look
you know shocker alert we're not going
to solve this issue on this podcast
today but
you know you're on one camp during covet
don't tell me what to do with my body i
put whatever i want with my body don't
tell me what to do it's like well that's
sort of the abortion
uh the pro
choice mentality is don't tell me what
to do with my body well you're murdering
someone it's not it's just it's such a
hard thing to answer that it's a
constant conversation it's going to
constantly be
with the basically where the courts are
are situated right now with the
conservative justices it's going to be a
situation this brings us back to the
conversation we were having for weeks
and weeks and weeks is
is biden gonna pack the court you never
hear anything about that anymore but the
the this is this is going to be a
causation minority rule is what it is 68
of the country is in favor of
access to abortion care it's like with
the guns 90 percent of people want
stricter gun laws the representatives
are not
honoring the will of the people okay so
so real quick a couple points here one
the rape and incest case of abortion is
less than a tenth of a percentage point
okay okay so
now i don't disagree
you guys are doing you're debating on
roe right so
what happens if roe gets overturned
it's federally illegal but it takes it
back to the states right the states get
to decide so so you asked who benefits
from this
my stance would be the democracy
benefits for this because
everybody broadly agrees even ruth bader
ginsburg said that roe was wrongly
decided that it's a bad legal precedent
it's a bad case it's possibly the worst
case in in history of the court the way
it was decided nowhere in the
constitution does it say anything about
abortion and that's what the court is
there to do is to interpret the laws
right so what happens if roe gets
overturned then the people can put it up
for a vote they can they can vote on it
in congress right you can vote to make
it federally legal why why is it that we
have nine justices in these cloaks and
robes
reigning in their decision for the rest
of the country right
you asked who wins democracy wins if roe
gets overturned the people should stand
up and vote and i don't think democracy
is winning though is the thing i i think
i think it's it's the opposite i i think
we're again minority rule i get your
point and it's a good one and i i'd be
interested in reading that uh ruth bader
ginsburg quote because i think it's uh
it's a little deep in that yeah if you
could pull that up it'd be great
um but uh you're bringing yes
you're right
if we can get if we can decide then as
if congress honored the will of the
people we would have a
democratic debate about the subject no
and i think i think that's absolutely
the point here is that it's not up to
these nine justices to have passed it in
the first place i think
and this speaks to a broader point of
the the
warping of the power that the court has
taken over that they just get to decide
off-whim what is and isn't federal law
right so it's like i i think the best
thing that we can do is have a debate on
this case and let the people decide and
as you say let congress agree and listen
to the will of the people because
we need to get back to some form of that
and give the people a voice again
but their their stance that it's because
it was never mentioned in the
constitution
doesn't mean they can rule on it uh
there's a lot of things that we have
laws on the books for that are not
mentioned in the constitution
transportation being one of them you
know what i'm saying and that we have
all kinds of federal regulations
regarding transportation so that's just
a weird take to have you know as a as a
as a supreme court justice well you know
it's not in there so we can't we have no
no no no say over that's just weird i
don't know what you got pat yeah man
we've been i i don't know and by the way
here's here's uh uh here's what i'll
tell you when it comes down to guns
right okay i lived in california i lived
in texas and i lived in florida okay in
california i uh went to buy a gun and i
went and bought a
shotgun and a rifle maybe i bought a
semi i don't know what i bought over
there i bought a few things
did a background check took me 30 days
to be able to pick up my stuff i don't
know what the timeline was but it was a
minute i couldn't get it that day could
have been a week could have been 30 days
but i didn't leave with the stuff that i
bought that day fine
i went to texas in texas i uh went to a
store
and i bought an m4 i think i bought two
of them with the magazine with all the
stuff walk that five minutes later took
it to my car by the way when you did my
interview i opened up to say you saw my
m16s you're like oh i see that guy
i just i
shot the military
so here's what i did okay so you come
over here you know what i like i like
the fact that a person if you don't want
to have people get guns early move to
california or run for office in your
city and state and go help change the
laws okay go help in that state get
people behind you get a strong argument
get either get behind somebody
or you go do it right if you think
a guy's going to be good against
desantis and you don't want the centers
to be re-elected because you think
florida's going wrong direction either
find somebody that's going to beat the
santas or go move to california or new
york it's your choice by state right to
do that
with this argument here as well the same
same happens because
you know
those stories you read i mean
i've i've read both sides of the story
where hey look at all these great
innovators that their parents didn't get
an abortion they almost thought about
getting an abortion how about that how
about this person that you know was
going to be the president and parents
had one point out about getting an
abortion and you read those stories like
what does the world look like without
those people oh my god couldn't even
imagine world without these guys so how
many stories are there that the mom and
the dad at one point thought about
getting an abortion and that person
ended up becoming great so who's right
on left and the right oh my god but this
person got raped in system okay so very
very so the exception to the rule which
is very small percentage they throw
those arguments up and it gets people
riled up right
so then you go to the other side and you
say okay your body your choice yeah how
come you didn't say that two years ago
how come he said that the last two years
which is kind of what you were talking
about why the hypocrisy so you're then
noticing the level of hypocrisy on both
sides
that comes out with arguments like this
and the lack of consistency
and you see leaks in arguments you only
want your body your choice when it
favors you but you don't want your body
your choice when it doesn't favor you
because you want everybody to take the
vaccine what happened to your body your
choice it's my body i don't want to get
the vaccine you better get about you
don't care about my health dude it's my
body i'm going to do whatever i want to
do my body why are you forcing me to do
it and then the part that i have a
challenge with in regards to abortion is
i don't want to pay for it
if you went and got had sex unprotected
sex nobody told you to not use a condom
you chose i feel better when i have
unprotected sex no problem
it's your choice i don't care i'm just
not paying you abortion you pay for it
you want to get an abortion you go in
and pay for it i'm not going to pay for
it i didn't have sex that night i didn't
feel good when you had sex you had sex i
didn't feel good you had sex it felt
good for you i didn't get any of that
joy why am i getting the pain so let me
get this straight i didn't get that
great feeling of sex for you get for the
last hour long of it and i'm supposed to
do the bad you know to pay the price for
the bad part that you don't want to pay
the 500 bucks whatever the numbers i
don't want to do that i don't want to go
through it um
everybody in their family says a private
abortion story i have some i'm sure you
have some and you have some you see some
folks who brag about how many abortions
they've had i also don't agree with that
this lady right here has got a shirt on
saying i've had 21 abortions
a comedian a comedian got up and i don't
know who this comedian was about a year
and a half ago the girl with the curly
hair and said let me tell you how many
abortions i've had this is how many
abortions i've had matter of fact i'm
gonna go get more abortions
so that stuff is stupidity by the way
that's also the exception that's not the
majority so i'm not also putting them as
these guys are at fault no i'm a
reasonable enough of a person but i
think to leave it to the states
if guns are left to states
if this is left to state the way it
happened if you go look at the history
of
roe v wade is uh you know two supreme
court justices at the time
were either retiring uh tyler or they
were stepping away and this young
attorney comes in like really really
young and just somehow got this thing
through and it would have never happened
in this case ever but this was a very
interesting unique situation that they
capitalized and
at the end of the day in regards to the
information being leaked you know oh my
god i can't believe the information is
leaked and all that stuff and one side
is saying who cares about the person
that leaked the information i'm morgan
republicans are more targeting this than
protecting women's rights i'm sorry when
somebody leaked information to you on
the other side about hillary you were
pissed off to say why would you leak
this is irresponsible so then goes more
hypocrisy in the situation here at the
end of the day if it's 68
let's find out if it's 68
if it really is 68
maybe we're going to find out it ain't
68 percent maybe we're going to find out
those polls are full of [ __ ] maybe we're
going to find out more people are for
like unless if it's rape or incest or
this i i'm sorry i just don't support it
we don't know let them make that
decision for themselves and you know i
have my own position on this it's my
where i stand with this but it's
different for everybody else so i you
know not whoopi joy comes out and joy
says you know
a woman we should go on a sex strike
that's the bad news for you by the way
oh yeah we should go on a sex strike
okay don't give it up no no you can't
give it up just use a damn condom when
you give it up why not she said that
about because of the abortion yeah well
condoms break it look i think i have bad
news for joy behar nobody's gonna be
upset if she goes on a sex strike nobody
that's a good point it is the question
is is it health care or is it not health
care and is it a society's
responsibility to
cover from their tax
burden
health care
in general right
and you can make that argument that's an
argument to be had and
why we need better representatives well
this goes back to your initial point
that it's not a black and white
situation there's so many gray areas
once you go here and you peel the onion
well you know what it's only in this
case well it's a rape it's an incest
well you get the life of the mother and
then what's up then this story and then
well actually it's been uh is it six
weeks is it twelve weeks it's just such
a complicated
situation that it takes such
grace to walk around and then obviously
if you say the wrong thing you're gonna
get canceled next thing you know joy
behar is doing a sex strike on you you
don't get any from joy catastrophic i'm
sure most single men in hollywood are
devastated right now because of her
going on a sex strike this is war on
women gays people of color you know what
they're saying if you let them do this
what happens next when they don't let
you have interracial marriages oh my god
now you're getting over dramatic on
interracial marriages who's gonna get
there and say we're not gonna do
interracial marriages but again
considering there's an interracial
marriage on the supreme court yeah at
the moment
yeah but but listen at the end of the
day okay what's obama's famous words
after his first term what did he say
he says elections have what consequences
go
hey trump
may have
you can call him whatever you want but
if you're a republican
he got you a 6-3 advantage and that's
the biggest insurance policy that's
going to last
for 10 20 30 years it is rich of
mcconnell though called the the the
politicization of the supreme court when
the reason there are there's a 6-3 is he
politicized the f out of the supreme
court yeah that's not dennis i don't i
don't think anybody disputes that
mcconnell is an interesting cat himself
absolutely so interesting him and
schumer are probably part of the same
camp to me him schumer pelosi they're
they're part of this thing i understand
that just another real quick daily dose
of irony uh
who you know the the left wants to fight
to the death for planned parenthood
right and the largest proportion of
abortions in the country are by black
women right who is margaret sanger the
founder of planned parenthood she was a
well-known eugenicist who wanted to
prevent the birth of
uh mentally challenged people and blacks
in the country
i just think it's irish i've heard that
argument i don't think that's entirely
accurate but i i've heard i've heard
that argument before and i think that's
tyler gets his information for some from
certain sources no no but nothing he
said isn't necessarily true but i think
i don't think it's the entire truth
again it's we all we tend to as you know
especially today when politics has
become religion
glom on to one part of the argument and
hold on to that when it's like yeah but
also this you know what i mean is putin
evil well not to not to his motherland
he's not right so
what's what's the what's the answer we
don't have it here at the pbd podcast
but this was great discourse folks i'm
curious where you stand comment below
i'd love to actually read your
commentary see what you stand with this
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]